[Music]
Chris waters here at San Diego comic-con
with GameSpot on our stage joining me
now Sebastian right cuts the creative
producer for sacred three and we're
gonna talk about sacred three a lot and
see the game in action but first I want
to talk to you about comic-con is this
your first time here yes this is my
first comic-con pretty exciting it's so
awesome yeah I'm completely blown away
it's like they make me a kid again they
make yeah right it's that feeling of see
you know seeing stuff that even if you
maybe didn't like it play with the toys
or the suit watch the videos when you
were a kid you still get nostalgic for
just sort of the way a lot of this or
the art and creativity is presented here
it's insane I mean you go to one piece
and then stock book of stuff from your
youth okay
awesome then you go one one thing mix by
the way we have no classic masters of
stuff please yeah I was wearing a
masters in university shirt yesterday
that I bought at comic-con the day
before it's a magical place but let's
talk sacred three because this is you
know a long-running series about it's
been about a decade since the first
sacred right right and it's a series
that a lot of people have really put a
lot of time into on your end but also on
the player and people people are very
passionate about this series so let's
talk about sacred threeways
give us the broad overview for folks who
maybe have been under a rock for the
past ten years
okay plus it was important to get new
interpretation into the whole sacred
thing and sacred three is basically the
whole aspect of sacred pushed into a
very arcane --is-- action-heavy
multiplayer area okay because it was one
of the elements that we really liked
about it was playing with other people
and it was so the designers that we find
really went a lot into this direction of
how much can we push it that playing
with other players is as easy as
possible mm-hmm so this whole yeah
nowadays it's hard to say arcade
experience because people think about
small indie games that they download on
XBLA and PSN but it's still this
old-school ish insert coin have fun and
kind of the immediacy of the action
right and just you know being able to
smash up a ton of what are these goblins
oh it's an area our grumbling heart that
is challenged with additional pirates
the bandits yeah we it's nice to see
them getting along and uniting over a
common cause of trying to murder you
what do you see here for example one of
this thing you can actually grab the
little gremlins and give them me best
like you know it from Double Dragon and
when you're finished with them you throw
them and they become projectiles to
throw it into other things yeah what it
like smacked into another noon who
smacked into the wall like that's and
that's that kind of maybe that's that
kind of arcade feel direc sanitary ward
no one no one in the game will tell you
that you have not enough attack points
to throw that guy anything you will be
able to do this kind of action like move
we don't have a touch with our own I
mean a test a dice test yes it's not
checking for numbers you actually do but
you push the stick to the left and do
yeah you get what you see
so if you roll aside from a fireball you
will emit the fireball it's not checking
if your touch skin is high enough if you
see that you're not getting hit by the
fireball it wound up and you're good not
so singed at all so what's speaking of
what we see this is uh looks like a dude
swinging a giant hammer
what kind of and there's a furious a
very very famous voice how should I say
he will stop flowers of fire and this
from the Saphira cultures name is marek
and he's the tanky guy now he now he has
picked up his first spirit which is
basically a special powerup item that he
can put into your weapons to get
additional benefits from it this guy for
example can trigger this guy can trigger
chain lightnings so the stronger you
make sure that this game with this guy
gets he's basically inbound into your
weapon and then you will have lightning
damage on your weapon additionally to
what the Saffir he brings in o essa'
fury already has a lot of fire base
attacks yeah we've been seeing some some
fire spewing I think a little bit
earlier but so you're putting like a
trapped spirit of some guy into your
weapon
it's leveling that spirit up the astral
empire of the evil guys so they use that
for their for their for their power for
their for their army but you free them
and then they help you okay and so the
nice idea about it is that you can
freely choose which one to put into your
weapon and this gives additional effects
to it and so that's just I mean that's
you know I never janenn the inventory
you can sort of shuffle that around
there's not gonna quick different
spirits but then also you've got you
looks like you've got to sort of spells
or something on the two shoulder buttons
here
judging from the the HUD up at the top
left so there are a lot of abilities in
play as well yeah the whole the whole
thing about sacred always was fans were
always happy about this whole combat art
combo thing how do you combine it what
combinations are possible we streamlined
it a lot so making sure that it doesn't
overwhelm you by throwing tons and tons
of different things at you without you
understanding them first but the cool
thing is that you will always have the
chance to pick two out of out of a bunch
of them to define how your character
wants to be and this doesn't stop with
the two main super attacks it also has
the chance that you say this whole
evading is not my thing I want to become
a wall so you choose the block instead
and then you simply stand there and
become invincible for a short moment and
is that is that an ability or that sort
of more of a passive attribute kind of
thing where you're sort of skewing your
character towards being covered it's
enacted for the disability I'm gonna so
locket feeling and spirit is in there to
make sure that this all the time the
cool thing is that it works in
multiplayer so well because you can
become a wall for your friends oh nice
people of people throwing stones at you
and it's the whole party yeah you said
you just happen
takes Rowlands on the shin no big deal
yeah you this guy doesn't look like he
was mine right now he seems fine totally
fine with it yeah speaking of
multiplayer we had another character
just drop in during this and who besides
having like really awesome hair what
reveal the Seraphim is the most classic
character from the from the whole IP
it's basically our angel like creature
in his and she she's from a race that is
sent from the from a culture that is
sent from from the gods to protect the
world yeah we can see her sort of wispy
blue wings coming out the back there
yeah this the more she used up her
palace the more you can see actually how
the wings spread out and okay so the
character model itself changes as you
develop your strengths and your powers
and even if you if you get the better
almost sets and you become more powerful
the wings will fold out and if you do
then the extreme power super moves it
basically will wipe the screen with the
wings it's a lot of fun too so we've
seen sort of that's and compared her to
the warrior we saw fighting alongside is
her style a little bit more nimble or
can she also skewed towards that kind of
like damage taking yeah all character
she she's more agile I wouldn't call
yeah a lot more agile but she still
packs a huge punch because it's more
like she's like heavenly punishment yeah
for those guys it's you shouldn't take
her lightly it's she's doing damage a
lot but she does does it a little bit
more subtle by cursing them first or
basically spreading out the holy word
which isn't very kind to the bad guys
it's not a nice word if you're the bad
guy yeah all right so we've actually
sort of gone out sort and now to like a
little port area these guys coming off
of this boat I talked to you a little
bit about just sort of the environmental
design and what kind of world you guys
are trying to create here in sacred 3
yeah it was some poor thing about sacred
it's the world is the world is the world
of sacred and in place some thousand
years after the other sacred so we
wanted to show off what does and carrier
look like now so in can we guess the
name of the work but what does it look
like now how has it changed and there we
set together and designed the whole
thing okay that was a lake before after
10,000 years the lake has vanished
because of
an earthquake over here and so we gave a
lot of it was important to have these
these things in there that reference to
the old sacred games and still give us
an opportunity to show how we see it how
it would look like now so you will find
brave rock in there but it's it has
changed completely and has become a very
grim place it's not the main capital
city anymore so fallen on hard times
more like an unlit City well okay I
guess that's a little bit more than just
hard times when your city becomes an
undead city almost roll yeah so this is
another that's another neat thing that I
was really enjoying games of this ilk is
when the size of enemies really scales
up and you feel like you're taking on
something that's really formidable
because it's towering over you yeah we
love to put this kind of challenges at
there at the players it's an easy easy
way to communicate that they should be
careful about this guy yep this is the
guy yeah this is the thing that makes
you well let's talk a little bit more
about the cooperative play so you know
this was just sort of a drop in it
looked like that happened you know mid
match is that something you do locally
is that something you do through online
connection all the time the base load
button thing of us this process make
sure people can play together I think so
we wanted to have the moment that a
classic situation as you sit at home you
play the game and a friend comes by so
you quit the game you have basically
have to quit the game because even if he
wants to play with you you start from
the beginning because yeah character or
he doesn't know the game so if your
character is level 20 and your friend
comes in and oppressor start we create a
level 20 character fine you guys all
simple guess success there you go
play with it this is the big advantage
that they instantly can join the fun
unless the game is very direct it's also
not about learning which numbers in your
how high is the number in your attack
pool how high is the number
defense pool big things flying at you
dodge yeah it's a very simple concept
out of the way
there's still tons of tons of detail in
there so how do you use the bombs will
you throw him at it directly how you
trying to roll image at his feet of make
him run into it so it's not like we
remove the code the complexity and the
possibilities from the whole system but
we wanted to make sure that that getting
into it is fast because when your friend
then played with you and said this was
awesome he's probably at the point where
he says I need something better than a
guest account login with my own account
I want to create my own carrier I want
to have built the character to this
point you know exists there's
satisfaction in that for sure but even
if it doesn't like to the guest the
guest account will have all the
possibilities he needs so he will be in
though in the next in the next when he's
next time the menu is the chance to
change his is ability secret level up so
if you prefer to have a night full of PN
sacred no problem the game will yeah and
the nice thing is you still can play
online okay so what happens is you with
your with your friend in front of the
console and the game says well we still
have two slots I found someone we should
play with you and then you joins you and
the fun gets more because the more
people that's a pretty steady maxim in
video game especially video games
especially when you're dealing with
cooperative situations just a quick
clarification that we saw we're seeing
xbox controller prompts on screen what
system is this running on or what was
this footage drawn from the you know
footage was drawn from the PC and your
discerning eye so I remember that
everyone with recording sessions
actually was what I was playing a lot of
the server of the Seraphim and I really
liked that animation that precedes the
sort of awakening the spirit charge that
the the like ghosts that sort of
effervesce is up from whatever thing you
just killed up because I'm curious about
the cooperative abilities because you
sort of mentioned a way they can
interact before one character sort of
serving as a wall for others are there
moves or abilities that are more
directly linked that sort of depend on a
cooperative player to execute so the
whole system is focusing a lot on the
even with small details if two players
attack one monster
it will get an additional damage boat
they will get an additional four damage
bonus because it's just harder for the
monster to defend yes he will get more
damage because and not only from the two
players there will also be a bonus in
then we take care of back attacks which
sounds very simple but with two players
it's very very valuable one distracts
the enemy and the other one is attacking
from behind it sounds very simple it
works very well
mm-hmm but we also have dedicated
features to it
for example the LT and the RT buttons
there that are flashing in the upper
right and lower right are also
triggering so-called co-op Corbett combo
dots that are really made for acting
together thus a fury for example casts a
meteor storm so every play I guess it
gets a little symbol around them to get
the info soon there will be amateur
crashing in so they can get themselves
into position and enjoy the fun why the
Seraphim
was that a meteor crash right there we
just saw it was sort of an area
explosion the indicator flash up there
exactly the Seraphim is one of my
favorite abilities because it it we can
simply simply the whole battlefield and
all the enemies have a very high chance
that they get knocked down when you hit
them and enemies in our game that get
knocked down will ended up in this they
understand in the state of executable so
you simply press a button and you do a
high jump of them and simply impale them
for with one hit and then it's over yes
and we have you know we have a nice
skill that is called chain execution and
so it really feels awesome when you
simply press the button three times and
you're just and it kind of bounces from
one enemy to the other and kills there
was one hit instead of a whole barrage
of attacks like tak tak tak tak
it seems like you know sort of
underlying that design philosophy is
this desire to create moments like that
where you are just sort of you know
you've you've got your enemies into a
position where you can dispatch them and
like a real satisfying it just kind of
like makes you grin because it's so yes
it's so rewarding I mean the contrast of
playing it alone and fighting through
the whole thing is that it gives you an
insight of how powerful your enemies are
and then when you're in multiplayer and
four people are unleashing the insanity
of their powers it's like whoa that's
green awesome it sounds good Sebastian
you talk about the game very
passionately and I love it so fun to
talk about to talk with developers who
like take such pleasure it's I think
it's very hard to fight through a
development of a game if you cannot feel
the passion for it and this is like yeah
this this whole arcade spirit that is in
there that it still has this this looks
a little bit like Double Dragon this is
a little bit like final fight and this
is definitely sacred so that's something
that made us very happy to see very cool
all right well I think that is connect
sort of come to the end of the sacred
three demo is time but tell me what
platforms is sacred 3 coming out on
because we saw it played with a
controller there even though it's
captured on PC yeah the controls have
been polished for all platforms we
dealing so we have it on PC we have it
on ps3 and we have it on xbox360 and
when August first of August August first
that's like next week yeah all right
cool that's the reason why I told you
before I'm really still got time to come
to San Diego comic-con and come on the
GameSpot stage Sebastien thank you so
much it's been a pleasure talking about
sacred 3 out next like literally a week
from today if my calendar of math is all
right calendar math is definitely a term
is horrible tool because I'm so close to
release and you're flying all over the
country all right well cool thank you so
much again Sebastien thank you for three
ladies and gentlemen check
next week
[Music]